bon jean marie madeleine duo battait
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors les
militaires donc qu'ils vont la junte au
pouvoir qui va donc entamer aujourd'hui
cette série de discussions quatre jours
de négociations
vous allez sûrement prendre part
justement à ces pourparlers avec votre
parti le cpa qu'est ce que vous attendez
concrètement de ces de cette rencontre
écoutez on attend déjà d'y voir un peu
plus de chair en attend d'avoir une
vraie feuille de route et on attend de
savoir comment on va mettre en place le
processus démocratique
enfin en guinée donc je pense que tous
les partis vont y participer en tout cas
toutes les grandes forces politiques
pour le participer on souhaite vraiment
que la junte militaire aujourd'hui il
donne sa feuille de route nous dise
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir former
enfin un gouvernement et combien de
temps va durer cette transition
justement la cedeao souhaite que les
civils reviennent au pouvoir dans un
délai raisonnable vous parlez d'une
feuille de route d'un processus qui doit
se mettre en place
est ce que finalement ça ne risque pas
de prendre trop de temps selon vous
écoutez les propos justement qu'on
prenne du temps en 2007 qui a eu déjà
des émeutes en guinée on a eu une
transition qui a été avortée avec
laquelle le capitaine moussa dadis
camara parce que la communauté
internationale avait fait la pression
pour que la jeune puisse partir très
rapidement je pense aujourd'hui que la
guinée a une chance inespérée si les
militaires veulent vraiment rentrer dans
un processus démocratique en faisant
participer une grande majorité de civils
au gouvernement et je pense qu'il faut
prendre le temps qu'il faut mettre un
calendrier et qui a beaucoup de
problèmes à régler en guinée notamment
l'instauration d'un vrai état de droit
avec une justice qui fonctionne puisque
aujourd'hui la justice ne fonctionne pas
on a des procès qui sont en cours dont
le procès du massacre du 28 septembre
2009 il ya un processus de
réconciliation nationale qu'il faut
mettre en place il y en a le tissu
social qui est complètement qui s'est
dit l'équipe parce qu'on a beaucoup de
problèmes techniques donc ce sont les
questions d'abord qu'il faut mettre sur
la table avant de commencer à dire qu'on
va donner une date pour des prochaines
élections présidentielles donc la guinée
a vraiment beaucoup de choses à faire il
ya de grands défis qu'elles tendent ce
nouveau gouvernement qu'il faut vraiment
mettre en place et à la pauvreté aussi
il ya l'euphorie aujourd'hui parce que
tout le monde est content la junte est
venu mais attendent dans deux semaines
je pense que les problèmes voire va ap
en fait la junte militaire il va falloir
qu'on parle de la façon dont on va
organiser le pays comment on va faire
pour que la population puisse manger à
sa faim pour mettre la population au
travail il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à faire avant de se mettre en
capacité pour des prochaines élections
présidentielles alors vous venez de le
dire que c'est l'euphorie actuellement
que la population a très bien accueillis
en tout cas
parking grande partie de la population
accueillie de manière plutôt positive ce
coup d'état est ce qu'il marque
finalement à un tournant pour la guinée
oui il marque le tournant pour la guinée
il faut pas oublier en fait le contexte
dans lequel s'est passé en fait ce coup
d'état il faut rappeler que le président
déchu monsieur alpha condé donc avait
modifié la constitution pour pouvoir
faire un troisième mandat et que ça
avait donné lieu à de très grandes
manifestations dans tout le pays avec la
constitution d'un front de défense
nationale de la constitution ça avait
donné lieu aussi à beaucoup de morts
parce que quand les gens ne voulaient
pas beaucoup beaucoup de d'acteurs de la
société civile de partis politiques
étaient intervenus pour réclamer à la
communauté internationale plus de
fermeté malgré tout sa alpha condé a
fait son troisième mandat et
malheureusement il est arrivé ce qui est
arrivé donc un bout de chou militaire
donc aujourd'hui il faut il faut
j'espère en tout cas que cette
transition sera salvatrice pour la
guinée parce que la guinée mérite là et
j'espère que la communauté
internationale sera présente pour nous
accompagner dans le processus
démocratique cette fois ci dernière
question alpha condé le deuxième
présidents africains à être renversé
cette année comment l'expliquez vous
comment est-ce que voilà vous vous voyez
ces coups d'état successifs qui arrivent
en afrique
ja plierait à plusieurs secteurs et un
le fait de vouloir modifier la
constitution mais c'est pas le premier
facteur le premier facteur je pense que
ce sont des présidents qui ont été déjà
mal élu il faut le dire ils ont été
parce qu'alpha condé a eu 18 % en 2010
il était en troisième position et il
s'est quand même il est quand même
pouvoir participer au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle donc c'est
d'abord un président qui aime aller mal
élu donc il n'est pas légitime et par
l'ensemble de la population
ensuite ils n'ont pas une vision
pour l'avenir de leur pays et donc ce
sont des gens aussi qui ont pillé leur
pays qui ont appauvri les populations et
qui ont mis un système de népotisme en
place donc ça ne pouvait pas passer je
rappelle que la guinée que l'ensemble
des guinéens plus de 70% des guinéens
vivent avec moins d'un euro par jour
donc vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et que la guinée est
potentiellement le troisième pays le
plus riche de la planète en raison de
ses ressources notamment en raison des
ressources de la bauxite et du fer lac
dont il détient la plus grande réserve
au monde de fer à ciel ouvert et elle
elle détient aujourd'hui la deuxièmes
réserves mondiales de bauxite et malgré
tout ce potentiel je parle pas des
autres minerais les guinéens sont
pauvres
merci beaucoup en tout cas marie
madeleine du baht et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du parti congrès populaire
africain et ancienne candidate à
l'élection présidentielle en guinée mais
sneijder